Mina doorman O'Hara
velkommen til Spencer Academy in Horsham
entre Toledo Oh cute set Ward's Nobel
Peace target in literature principal
Gorton Danville Trischka profit Arum
Svetlana
Alexeyevich
[Applause]
yo la firma tiempo Santa mobile proceed
alliterative or Segundo fountain tilde
last and built resurfaced after 'm
swetlana Alexeyevich piranhas monster
Magee evolved at monument over little
under walk mood evil till the Nobel
Prize in Literature for 2015 is awarded
to the belarusian writer said lana
Alexeyevich for her polyphonic writings
a monument to suffering and courage in
our time I'll now give the prize
citation in German on French I'll begin
with the French Pusan over polyphonic
memory we are the last Sioux Falls
addict wash are not well epic and in
German finally after C year field images
work the steam Leyden into the mood in
Anza website ein denkmal zest
[Music]
Alexeyevich lives in minced in
Belarusian and she is of course an
extraordinary writer for the past 30 40
years she's she's been busy
mapping the Soviet and post-soviet
individual but it's not really about a
history of events it's it's a history of
emotions what she's offering us it's
really an emotional world so these
historical events that she's sort of
covering in the various books for
example the Chernobyl disaster the
Soviet war in Afghanistan
and so on these are in a way just
pretexts for exploring the Soviet
individual and the post-soviet
individuals and she's she's conducted
thousands and thousands of interviews
with children with women and with men
and in this way she's she's offering
offering us industry
a human being about whom we didn't
really know that much at least not in
this systematic manner and at the same
time she's offering us a history of
emotions a history of the soul indeed I
have she she was overjoyed when I
finally when she finally understood who
was calling her and her comment was
fantastic
she has written prose or poetry written
fiction she's in fact journalist could
one say that you are widened the concept
of literature I think so not only is the
material that she's offering us new but
she's actually devised a new genre a new
kind of literary genre and that really
speaks to her that's part of her
achievement it's a true achievement so
not just in terms of material but also
in terms of four do you have a personal
favorite I do the Wolves womanly phase I
think it's called in English and that's
the one book that I would recommend that
people begin with and
it's an exploration of the Second World
War from from a perspective that was
before that book almost completely
unknown and it tells the story of
hundreds and hundreds of women who
participated we were at the front in the
Indies Second World War
almost well about 1 million Russian
women Soviet women participated in the
work in the wall and it's largely
unknown history and was a huge success
in the Soviet Union published sold more
than 2 million copies a final question
yes if one should stop the plan is a
common reading which well I would
recommend this one book about the female
soldiers and participants in the Second
World War
it's a very it's a touching touching
document and at the same time brings you
very close to these two every single
individual and in a few years all of
them will be gone thank you Sarah Donald
[Music]
you